[Music]
Pizza trap news Oh what does that mean
they trap a pizza no I think it's more
deviant it's a girl that stresses a
pizza to trap you in a relationship
where do they get booby trap from booby
trap like what's booby hakuna dude has
boobs
maybe it's an error like you made a
booby google it no no cuz it's an old
word right like we're gonna booby-trap
this whole place now and you type in
where the booby trap yes I know like
this is like it's like we're gonna
booby-trap this whole room it's like
fill it with dudes with breasts where do
you get the dudes with breasts from
think of it right as a guy when you see
tits you're like I'm awesome
yes idiot flash stupid so they're
trapping stupids
it's one that is laid to snare and
unsuspecting or idiot victim oh I never
thought boobies Matt's two person that
stupid [ __ ] booby just it's just the
comforting effect oh yeah it's like a
kindergarten insel submitted by spa or
ramen ramen yeah I do like very a lot
too you know I don't think I've ever had
like authentic [ __ ] what yeah you don't
have flies in the restaurant know what's
authentic way I went to a full
restaurant but everyone was like oh
that's not that's why you live over here
where we live it's like you know if it's
a bar restaurant in the mall that's why
I know they were making a play on words
but it would count on you saying it
wrong at the end if somebody's got an
accent go banana it's it's a white fall
true so the promise of a free pizza
tricked the alleged captor of a four
year old girl into revealing their
location
awesome what a baby I don't know though
pizza is really hard to resist rach
actually never resist B to me in any
context man named Virgil
that's why he went into crime is named
Virgil hopes I'd like that we've got a
comment you like my name is Virgil
they're cool because they're watching
our show but if they're not watching our
show committing crimes I'm like you're
[ __ ] Virgil but I knew what Bergdahl
growing up so Virgil is increased I'm
just kidding oh [ __ ]
so Virgil is the father of Yvette and he
abducted his daughter after her
grandparents got custody of her he
kidnapped his daughter yeah four year
old little girl why is that bad he's in
his custody the reason why he the
grandparents granted countries because
the court found that you vet was
suffering emotional damage living with
her father
oh damn she was removed from her
father's home they don't mention
anything about the mother so I'm not
sure where she is in the car shopping I
don't know
mom's always shopping or getting
massaged something like that yep Ward
shopping for groceries
oh what a selfish she's shopping for a
new place to get her nails done because
it wasn't happy but the limestone yeah
hear that all about it tell me about it
yeah so these grandparents are from
Hesperia here in California whoa that's
like the desert mm-hmm I know where
that's at that's worth all the people
that can't afford living in LA move to
El Nino about hysteria because of
sublime xeno frankly like everyone who
can't afford or Eagle Rock Eagle Rock
yeah yeah Northridge you go rocks
actually coming up it's either walks
coming up guys it's like the poor man's
Glendale oh yeah like you've just agrees
with anything Bart says because you're a
fan come on fan yeah can you like Bart I
think Bart's okay so far I just said the
Kevon things I agree with from the male
perspective time to do I'm trying to
split up the marriages are gonna work
divide and conquer
yeah
so right so Gary yeah so Gary's the
grandfather so he has punch Bob snail
Gary he found out that there was this
man named Harry
[Laughter]
yes Oh Harry it was Facebook friends
with Virgil and so Gary saw that because
Harry was I can't take there's a [ __ ]
Larry
so Harry was one of two people that
liked Virgil's Facebook profile photo so
that's how Gary ended up sending him a
message
Gary's the grandpa Harry's this friend
and the girl's name is Cherie neighbor
is what is she doing wearing a potato
sack
there's her 28 year old father [ __ ] that
guy why it's a bad picture here because
he lost custody of his own daughter
because of the emotional damage she was
climbing her Jeep for getting that part
I just keep you know what I've imagining
if I was a dad and somebody stole my
children's aways yeah I would want them
back and I would say [ __ ] the law that's
my blood I'm keeping them
I would also I also need to know what
the emotional damage is gonna say I
don't think in Asian families that
emotional damage is the real thing yeah
yeah that's not real there's no such
thing damage to it there's no such thing
it's bruises go away it's not broken
bones are okay abuse doesn't exist and
that's horrible what is abuse I don't
even know what that word is abuse yes so
here's the event with the grandpa Gary
that's a young house grandpa
her dad 35 35 year old grandpa and then
this is a Harry he's he's from that was
a Michele no he's from the UK what
though he's a gamer and that's how he
became friends with Virgil oh I thought
you were pointing to the mascot it also
looks like just as tall as him yeah I
don't know first Survey's I just thought
that he was posing with somebody else
look like a Harry he looks like a
Michelle for real yeah oh hey there's
other photos and he's ringing me covers
I'm sorry Harry I don't know if you
identify with another gender or what not
like you might he definitely does but I
thought you were a pretty girl okay okay
named Michelle and then I thought that
stuff animal was Harry then who would
this be Michelle yeah girl this is a
gamer that okay so anything look like
this it looked like this yeah like these
humans yes yeah it does it's this thing
I'll do it I'll do either but just put
me in because this looks like a dude
from San Diego no like I don't see the
Michelle oh well you are closer to the
screen than we are from this angle
no it doesn't wear girl I'm sorry so now
that's that's Harry okay okay the person
in the photo is Harry not the [ __ ]
mascot okay we got that [ __ ] move the
[ __ ] on know what Harry is a [ __ ]
hero
I don't know why you guys are so [ __ ]
we don't know anything about being a
Michelle or a man oh that's not what
matters here Harry is a hero cause Harry
the grandpa Larry and this is scary
yeah alright so I mean wait Harry and
Jerry no Gary and here
and Gary Harry cut Gary let's go this is
a message that Harry received from Gary
and it says Gary the grandpa okay hello
my name is Gary Forrester I see you our
friends on Facebook with a Mark Johnson
who happens to be Virgil Lamar Henley
and is the father of my four year old
granddaughter
Yvette right now my wife and I have been
given custody of Yvette and the FBI
child abduction task force is looking
for her if you can help me in any way
get a confirmed location of my
granddaughter Yvette I have a $2,000
cash reward for information that leads
to her safe return mark guy so then
that's when I would think that was a
scam like a phishing scam it's too
official that's when Harry started
messaging mark aka Virgil I say hands up
saying like hey do you want a pizza and
then Virgil says my kidneys hurt so bad
I can't eat but my wife does he's like
Oh Harry's like oh yeah why do your
kidneys hurt my mom just had two
surgeries for kidney stones sad face
what Pizza Virgil says I don't know
probably stones Harry says they're the
suckiest thing on earth haha
Virgil says I just passed them six weeks
ago Harry says the doctors thought I had
kidney stones in my appendix book and
then that's when Virgil gives the
address in Arizona along with the room
number because he thought that Harry was
sending a pizza over so thanks to Harry
within like two days of talking to
Virgil on Facebook he was able to get
the location and that's when he
immediately called they were also able
to get a dig in at stones pizza - Jesus
kidney stones they're talking about
kidney stones oh he's saying it's
probably stones - this one this question
okay cuz they said what pizza and he's
like probably stones and I'm like [ __ ] I
guess some places got [ __ ] lid up and
stones meet that sounds like a thing to
me I don't know is most
using goddamn episode of you're all
laughing at the knees you can't help it
Gary and [ __ ] Harry come on joy Harry
is a hero being and like making up names
yeah so here is gary and kim the grand
kabeer
young yeah I'm so happy that they got
the dog a granddaughter
yeah immediately they were saying how
when the car approached them with the
baby girl inside as she immediately ran
out and gave him a hug and they were
just so happy that they were able to get
her back in safe custody
are they posing next to the 10
commandments I don't know what that is I
would have also sent a pizza by the way
to stall him I'm pretty sure he sent a
picture it was like one bit of pizza we
got the police the police
we should ascend immediately I know it's
just chewy pizza with many toppings
doughnuts but I'm thinking like the
pizza pizza a doughnut it's all they eat
that's true oh I like I like Harry
Harry's a hero Harry the hero thanks
Harry for your investigative work I just
wonder how they friends in the first
place because you I told you because
there are gamers they met online all all
the information can you're so worried
about Julia said that it's Gary the
grandpa so I'm like who's the hero
Harry Harry the hero well the grandpa
reached out to Harry yeah so grandpa's
are here right the hero thanks again
both heroes they're a team Gary Gary let
me die hey guys would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos check it out up here
[Music]